hey this is press tow
Walker in this video I'll share a couple
of interesting probability questions
about decks of
cards problem one a standard deck of 52
playing cards is shuffled the cards are
turned up one by one until an ace
appears is the next card the one
following the first Ace more likely to
be the Ace of Spades or the two of clubs
a version of this problem appears in the
textbook by Sheldon Ross first course in
probability problem two a deck of 52
cards is placed in order the deck is
shuffled properly how many cards on
average do you expect to be in the same
spot as before the deck was
shuffled what if the deck was 10 cards
or 100 cards or n cards what would the
answer
be pause the video if you'd like to give
these problems a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these
[Music]
problems so let's solve the first
problem so intuitively it seems that the
two of clubs is more likely than the Ace
of Spades following the first Ace if the
first Ace is not the Ace of Spades then
either card is equally likely but if the
first Ace is the Ace of Spades then only
the two of clubs can appear so it seems
that the two of clubs should be more
likely than the first Ace this is what
most people think and this was also my
first reaction but of course this is
wrong it turns out both are equally
likely so let's do this calculation
we'll start out with the Ace of Spades
following the first Ace a deck of 52
cards can be arranged in 52 vectorial
ways every ordering can also be obtained
by arranging the 51 other cards and then
inserting the Ace of Spades in one of 52
positions for each of the 51 factorial
orderings there is exactly one spot to
place the Ace of Spades to follow the
first Ace so the probability of the Ace
of Spades after the first Ace is equal
to the number of ways to arrange the Ace
of Spades after the first Ace divided by
the number of ways to arrange all 52
cards this is equal to 51 factorial / 52
factorial which equals 1 over
52 so now think about this calculation
and every single spot that we referred
to the Ace of
Spades in fact the exact same logic will
apply to the calculation if we change
the card to the two of
clubs it's exactly the same calculation
there are 51 factorial ways that you
could put the two of clubs after the
first Ace and there are 52 factorial
ways that you could arrange the deck so
once again this probability is equal to
1 over 52
and therefore the actual answer is that
the two of clubs is just as likely as
the Ace of Spades following the first
Ace both of them are equal to 1 over 52
and that's the
answer even though we've done this
calculation carefully it still just
seems wrong so is there any other way to
understand the answer so notice we have
a deck of 52 cards and the probability
is 1 over 52 2 so if we had a deck of n
cards the probability would be 1/ n so
let's do an example where N is a smaller
number let's do n is equal to 3 and see
that in fact the probability works out
to 1 over 3 so we'll take a deck of
three cards and the probability should
be one over three for both cases so
we'll say a deck has three cards of the
Ace of Spades the two of clubs and the
Ace of Hearts so how many ways are to
arrange a deck of three cards there are
three factorial which equals six
different ways to order the deck so
let's just put them all out so now we
want to take the very first Ace in each
arrangement and see which card
immediately follows it so in the first
Arrangement it's the two of clubs in the
second Arrangement it's neither the Ace
of Spades nor the two of clubs in the
third Arrangement it's again neither of
those two cards in the next Arrangement
it will be the Ace of Spades then we
have the two of clubs and finally we
have the Ace of
Spades so following the first Ace the
probability that we have A2 of clubs is
equal to the probability we have an Ace
of Spades and each of these is equal to
2 over 6 which equals 1 over3 so this
proves that our intuition was not right
but our careful calculation was correct
both probabilities are equal to each
other
now let's solve problem
two so in a deck of 52 cards there are
52 factorial ways to randomly order the
deck of cards this is about 8 * 10 ^ of
67 which is an astronomically large
number if you counted one arrangement
for every second of the age of the
universe which is about 14 billion years
that is 4 * 10 ^ 17 which is still less
than 10 to to the power of
18 so every random shuffle of a new deck
of cards is likely a specific
arrangement of cards that has never
happened
before so after you Shuffle How likely
is it that the first card will be in
exactly the same spot of the first
position there are 52 equally likely
positions the first card could go so the
probability that it's in the same spot
is 1 over 52
but this is true for each card the
second card the third card and so on so
let XK be a random variable that's equal
to one if the K card is in the same spot
that happens with probability 1 over 52
and let it be equal to Zer otherwise so
we will calculate the expected value of
XK this is equal to 1 * 1 over 52 which
equals 1 over
52 so now let's do our calculation we
want the expected number for each of
these cards so we want to know how many
of the 52 cards stay in the same spot so
we want the expectation of the sum of X1
+ X2 plus so on to
x52 the expectation of a sum is equal to
the sum of the Expectations by linearity
of the expectation operator so this is
equal to the expected value of X1 plus
the expected value of X2 all the way up
to the expected value of
x52 but each of these expectations is
equal to 1 over
52 there are 52 terms that are equal to
1 over 52 which means this expectation
is equal to 1 therefore in a random
shuffle you can expect one card to be in
the same position but what if the deck
had n cards for n greater than or equal
to one we just to modify the argument
from n is equal to
52 so wherever we have 52 we can replace
that with n because the exact same logic
will apply each of the N cards will have
a 1 over n chance and there will be n
cards so we just change 52 to be n in
each of these arguments and we end up
with exactly the same result if you have
a deck of n cards you still will expect
one card to be in the exact same
position this is true for any size deck
n greater than or equal to one so it
could be a deck of just one card or 10
cards or 100 cards or a thousand cards a
myriad of cards one lack of cards one
million of cards one crow of cards one
billion of cards a Google of cards or
even grams number of cards in a random
shuffle you can expect one card to be in
the same position after
shuffling what a surprising
result thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time